- Well,, wait, this is gonna be,
is it 35 years?
- Yes.
- So you're about to celebrate
35 years together?
(audience cheers)
That's incredible. That's incredible.
I'm just saying it doesn't always happen,
especially for people in the business,
especially for two artists.
Like that's incredible.
Let me know like what your secret is.
Maybe I'll use it next time.
- We have no secret.
- We have no secrets, yes.
- Are y'all doing anything big?
Are you doing anything to celebrate?
- We don't usually do a big
thing for our anniversary.
We usually like hang out
and go to dinner, you know?
I mean really we're-
- We make dinner.
- Yeah, we're pretty boring.
- But that's nice.
But I feel like our jobs
are always constantly going
and doing stuff,
so it's nice to do-
- Yes, exactly. Exactly.
- I think we like, one of
the things we like about
our anniversary though I have to say is
that it falls in September
and I absolutely love the
month of September because-
- Ooh, fall in general.
- Yeah, I mean the light
is so beautiful and also for
some reason New Year's is,
you know, supposed to
be the start of the year
but it never feels like the
start of the year for me.
September feels like when the
year starts, it's hopeful.
- [Audience] Aww.
- Do you think that coincides with like-
- Is that corny? I don't know.
I wasn't even trying to elicit an "Aww"
but somehow
(audience laughs)
just talking about September got an "Aww."
- For my family it's because
I have kids, so like,
it's like school starts around then.
So it feels like the school
year kind of starts for me too.
In a totally non-romantic way.
(audience laughs)
Just that's when I buy school supplies.
So that's what that is.